all right elizabeth
elizabeth oh where'd you grow up where
are you from originally
i grew up in clayton california
clayton is where
it is up in the san francisco bay area
near walnut creek in the east bay
[Music]
and tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents as a kid
yes
my parents stayed together until my mom
actually passed in 2016 from
alzheimer's i'm sorry it's okay
how would you describe your childhood
really stressful really traumatic and a
lot of drama
a lot of unnecessary drama
my dad he was a southern baptist
preacher from texas
and my mom was from england a small town
in england
and
how they got together he was in the air
force in england
and that's how they met
um
my mom ended up taking the queen mary
when she was 21 years old to texas and
marrying my dad and i don't think that
she really knew him at all
she had no idea what she was getting
herself into
um
where shall i begin
so
they had my oldest brother and then
three years later they had uh another
and my other brother steve so there was
two boys
and then there was a ten-year gap and
they had me and my little brother my
little brother's three years younger
than me
my dad he was very angry i would say
it's it was beyond anger it was more
like rage he had a rage issue
and he was very physically abusive
um
and he was a preacher
and then my mom she was the principal of
the school that was attached to the
church so we were the preachers kids and
the principal's kids too which was a lot
of a lot of pressure
especially with what was going on at
home
uh the the contradiction
that i saw as a young child was just
i couldn't get over it it it was very
confusing for me
so
you know my dad he would go into a rage
over just anything you know for example
he would yell at me or hit me for taking
my shoes off when i came into the house
you know why'd you take her shoes off
you know and
so i would leave my shoes on and then
the next week i would get in trouble for
my shoes being on
so
nothing made sense there was no
consistency there was really no method
to his madness so what i learned to do
as a young child
was
to read energy
so i could sense his anger you know and
and either
change my behavior or go hide
i learned at a very young age to become
very small
almost invisible and just to have no
needs because there was really no room
for that
in my house
he also was sexually abusive towards me
i i don't know if he did things to my
brothers i can't i don't know i wasn't
there i don't you know i was in the
house but i don't know
they claimed that he didn't
uh so what would happen like say
saturday night
you know i was six or seven years old
someone would come into my room it was
dark i didn't know who it was and they
would be on top of me i couldn't breathe
and then it would be over and then the
next day i would have to go to church
and you know sit in the pew and watch my
dad preach
and
by about the end of the church service i
would have such a pounding headache
that i could barely see straight and
then by kind of the end of the afternoon
i would just be vomiting
because i don't think that
my body knew how to process what was
happening i think it was just it was too
much for me i was just a little girl
and this went on for years and
unfortunately my mom you know she she
grew up in england during world war ii
and
they were dropping bombs and you know
her life was in danger and then she told
me she was raped by a neighbor when she
was only 10 or 11 years old
and it never got dealt with you know she
said i you know this guy man did this to
me and she was called a liar you know
and
so my mom had her own trauma
that was never dealt with and i think
you know energetically the reason my mom
and dad came together it just dovetailed
perfectly is because it just continued
the craziness um
so she was not
for whatever reason able to protect us
she really she did nothing to protect us
and you know i think that there's a lot
of men that can you know fly off the
handle and get angry and lose their
temper and the mother's there to you
know kind of stop don't do this you know
but you know she didn't do that
so
i would say the
the most painful thing because i learned
to also to disassociate as a child like
i would just leave my body
um especially when my dad would hit me
you know they called it spanking but it
was like i mean he would beat us till
we'd have bruises on our butts and
broken blood vessels and you know things
like that
you know and then that way it was it was
a perfect cover because nobody could see
it no one could see the bruises you know
because i'd have clothes on and
but the hardest part was watching him
beat my little brother
he was three years younger than me and
he was like this toe head kid with these
big blue eyes and he was just so
beautiful he was like a little angel
baby and
i watched my dad break his spirit
like i i witnessed it
and
it was
it was devastating it was absolutely
devastating um
he would turn
blue because he couldn't breathe
and my dad just wouldn't stop hitting
him and my mom would just stand there
she would just watch or she would leave
the room you know because she didn't
want to see it
but i saw it i saw all of it but she
didn't feel like she could stand up to
him i don't think so i
i think my mom
never felt like she had a choice in her
life you know i think she felt trapped
her entire life
and and fit into that victim martyr role
you know and and that's a very hard role
to give up because if you give up being
a victim and a martyr you have to take
responsibility
and i think for my mom if she would have
confronted my dad about his behavior she
would have had to admit that there was
something very wrong
so i think it was just easier to
to ignore it or to just you know
somehow bypass it in her mind
so
you know my little brother
he suffered a lot he took a lot and i i
think my oldest brother did too
my oldest brother and i we no longer
have a relationship because he's just so
difficult and i think damaged
from you know what he went through as a
child
so yeah this went on for years
and
i really
i don't know how i survived i think the
disassociation really saved my life
otherwise i would have probably split
and become schizophrenic or something or
just you know completely lost my mind
so i learned to survive when i was 12 by
using drugs and alcohol that's when i
was first introduced to drugs and
alcohol
my oldest brother helped with that
because that's what he was using
and i don't think he was trying to hurt
me
i think it was his remedy and so you
know he he knew what i was going through
and then when i was around that age this
these
boys moved in next door and one of the
one of the boys that moved in next door
he was three years older than me and he
became a drug dealer so he would supply
me with drugs
um
i
you know did lsd it kind of opened my
mind i think i saw energy for the first
time i realized that there was more
than
just the physicality of life it was
really beautiful um
yeah it really it really gave me a lot
of strength
you know i used marijuana i did you know
alcohol and then um
i started smoking crack when i was 14.
and for whatever reason you know i
didn't i liked it but i didn't like it
that much i didn't really like feeling
that out of control um so a friend gave
me some crystal meth
and that was home
like the the crystal meth was right it
was it it made me feel in control
i think from all the
the trauma in my childhood my adrenals
my adrenal glands were just so drained
that i had no energy like i didn't have
natural energy i was depressed a lot i
would want to sleep i didn't want to
really do much
so when i did crystal meth it was it was
like someone turned the lights on i
became alive and i wanted to be around
people and i had like this inner courage
and
it was really it was a lot of fun
um so i think that's why i didn't become
a crackhead the crystal meth was better
thank god really um but
you know i kind of went in and out of
drugs during high school and what's
really what i find really interesting
when i look back
is you know kind of when i hit puberty
is when i started using drugs and
instead of getting into guys i got into
drugs because guys just scared me
like i was scared of men i was scared of
sex i had my mom you know in one ear
telling me you know sex is dirty sex is
wrong nobody will ever want you if you
have sex before marriage and then you
know my dad on the other side of me you
know touching me
so it was
it was i was very confused i was very
confused
so by the time i graduated high school i
think i was just so
fragmented i didn't know who i was i
didn't know what i wanted you know i was
really pretty and so everybody liked me
and i looked okay and i think that that
was part of the problem um
[Music]
has been a problem in my life is my
outer appearance did not match what was
going on inside at all you know i kind
of learned to be a chameleon and fit in
with whoever and act how i needed to act
to get what i wanted you know or to
protect myself or whatever
so
um
my first relationship that i actually
did get into was with a man named tom
and my dad's name is tom
and my both my grandfather's names were
tom and one of my uncles is named
so here was another tom and
at the time i was seeing him i was not
using drugs i was drinking
and i didn't know you know at 18 years
old that you could become addicted to
another person
but i became
addicted to him chemically addicted to
him to the sex to the horrible way he
treated me it kind of triggered
retriggered the childhood stuff
so there was something about it that
felt comfortable even though it was
incredibly painful
um
and that went on for three years
and um
it ended very badly
i actually ended up getting really
violent
and
damaging his home
getting charged with assault and battery
and i fought the case because he had
done things to me
and the d.a decided to drop it so i
walked away
thank god
but after that i decided to go to
london and live there i was in college
at the time trying to be in college i
was not a good student there was a lot
of learning disorder issues that i had
to deal with dyslexia and you know stuff
like that
because when i was young i remember this
is how i know i disassociated i would
get test papers back
and there would be an f on them and the
the test would be completely blank
and i would never remember the test
being in front of me
i was that checked out
so
that's sort of how i stumbled around in
the world during you know my childhood
um
but when i was in london
you know of course i kind of attracted
drugs
you know started doing ecstasy and going
to the clubs and that just felt really
good it felt like
ah
you know like here's a good time here's
some
here's people that are nice to me and i
feel really good and i feel full of love
and
when i came home it was
1994
and i was just craving more of the club
scene so i went to san francisco
and started going to the clubs there
house music got really into that and
then of course the crystal meth use
kicked in again
and those were some of the funnest times
and also some of the darkest times of my
life i made some really bad decisions
and put myself in very dangerous
situations i really
don't know how i survived i think that
you know god's always looked out for me
you know
[Music]
um are you religious
i wouldn't say that i'm religious
because you know religion was really
shoved down my throat in an unhealthy
way growing up that's why i ask yeah but
i definitely believe in god i do
i
i don't think that we were you know
created by happenstance i just don't i
think that there's a
there's a higher intelligence that just
creates love and it just creates and it
creates and it creates and it helps us
create
and it never wants to destroy anything
no matter how ugly it is or evil it is
it just wants to love it
and that's
that's really that's where i believe i
come from
you know as i look at myself today in
the mirror it's like wow i'm a child of
god
and nobody can take that away from me
no amount of abuse or drugs or
anything nothing can take that away from
me that's mine
what about you have you had you have a
family of your own or children or
marriages no i um
i never got married and i never wanted
to have children i was just telling a
friend last night
when i was living in the bay area in my
30s i joined this dating service and i
would you know be on a date with a
normal guy and he'd be like yeah i want
to get married and have three kids and i
would just be like
i could feel my heart like
like
the thought of getting married and
having kids was like asking me to run
into a burning house
it's just like it wasn't happening
i was so overwhelmed i was so
overwhelmed by
just the normal things that most people
do that they don't even think about it
they just do it and for me it was like
oh no no no no
kids family first of all i i knew i was
fully aware of my brokenness and i
didn't want to put another human being
through that
i knew
i wasn't qualified to be
a mother or a wife
and i was fully aware of that
um
you know and the other thing is i was
just terrified of commitment
responsibility you know wanting to stay
a child wanting to be
irresponsible i think when you have kids
you have to grow up really quick or you
don't you know some people don't
so um
yeah and it was really interesting in my
in my 20s
i ended up dating a drug dealer surprise
surprise
and i was just drowning i remember one
day i looked in the mirror and i didn't
recognize myself and this there was this
voice that was like you're better than
this liz
you're better than this so i pulled
myself out of it and i moved and i
changed my phone number
and i stopped doing crystal meth on my
own
um
i was still drinking you know
i was out at a bar one night with
my little brother actually and a couple
of good friends of mine and i met a man
and we ended up in a relationship for
three years
and he loved
me he really he did he loved me
you know but i had so much
trauma that was just like right under
the surface
i could only go
you know so deep with people
no matter how much they love me
because i didn't love myself
i felt broken i felt unworthy i felt
crazy
i felt unlovable
that's the real core of it all isn't it
absolutely
because i felt unlovable
because if my parents treated me like
that there must be something wrong with
me
you know that's how i think i made sense
of it
so he and i were together for about two
years and then i started using drugs
again
because the
intimacy
with him really triggered a lot for me
a lot of stuff that was under the
surface
and i broke up with him i ended the
relationship and he was devastated
and i was devastated and i ended up
trying to kill myself
um
it didn't work clearly
but i i checked myself into the hospital
and i was there for a week and got
stable got on some medication
and then went back out in the world and
i went back to the san francisco club
scene and within a year i was you know
doing meth again every day
i got to the place where i started to
get psychosis when i would use you know
i would just instantly go to crazy or
paranoid
so
i'll never forget it was a sunday i was
in this apartment in san ramon
california
and i was looking at this bag of drugs
you know this bag of meth and i was like
i can't imagine my life without you and
i can't keep doing this
and so once again there was that exit
door
you know
so i drank like half a bottle of ghb and
with some sleeping pills and
i left a note i wrote a note you know
just apologizing to everyone
that i wasn't
doing this to hurt anybody
but it was just because of my own pain
and i woke up the next morning on the
floor i had vomited everything up on my
side thank god because usually what
happens is
you know people are on their backs they
vomit and they out you know goes into
their lungs and that's how they die
um and when i woke up i didn't know if i
was dead or alive
you were trying to kill yourself i was
definitely trying to yeah this was not a
cry for help this was i'm done
and i kind of just looked around and my
body was in a lot of pain
and i called a friend and i told her
what i'd done and an ambulance came and
i went to the hospital again and this
time i was there for three weeks because
they knew if they let me out i was just
gonna try to do it again
so this friend of mine she contacted my
oldest brother and she just said your
sister's gonna die like you guys have to
help her you know and i had i hadn't
talked to my dad i didn't talk to my dad
for 13 years
i was so pissed at him
so my oldest brother showed up at the
hospital actually my oldest my two older
brothers my brother steve came into town
he lived here in la and this was in the
bay area and my mom and my little
brother they showed up at the hospital
and the nurse came and said you know
your family's here and i said is my dad
here and they she said
no.
it's your mom and and your three
brothers and i just said you know tell
them to go away i don't want to see them
i was pissed that i was alive
i was just pissed i was so angry i
didn't
i was like i can't even kill myself you
know i mean it was like i just felt like
i couldn't
i couldn't get what i needed anywhere
you know so here i am and i'm angry and
i just want my family to [ __ ] off
so my brother came to the hospital every
single day my oldest brother until i
would talk to him and finally i talked
to him and he was like you know liz
we're gonna
we're gonna send you somewhere and get
you some help we've decided as a family
you know you need help
so they shipped me down here to newport
beach
to a rehab
and i was impatient there for nine
months
you know most people go to rehab for
like 30 days
you know 60 days 90 days and
but i literally like i didn't know how
to live
i didn't know how to just be normal
i think my nervous system was so
disregulated my whole body was
dysregulated and my brain my brain
chemistry was just it was just so out of
balance
so i go to this place is it okay if i
say the name of the place okay it's over
living by the sea it's still around
so i go there and i'm terrified you know
i'm i'm 29 years old and i look like i'm
12 and you know i'm just like a deer in
headlights
um
and there's a man there who was my case
worker he was going to be my
my counselor
drug and alcohol counselor
and i walk into his office and i look on
his desk and there's a dallas cowboys
mug on his desk and i was like
my dad and brothers were like avid
dallas cowboy fans
and
he turns around and he looks at me and
he goes hi liz and i was like oh are you
from texas and he was like yes i am and
i was like let me guess he used to be a
preacher and he goes yeah i was i was
like what is going on i was like
i was like okay and so i told him i told
him the parallels you know and he goes
nothing's nothing's by accident
his name is david
and
he literally
loved me back to life
he did
he was like the first man
in my life that just wanted to love me
and didn't want to touch me or exploit
me or
you know do anything
to hurt me
and so for about six straight months i
would meet with him
every day and you know we would talk
about stuff and
i remember one day he was like he looked
at me and i said what he goes why do you
always have to look so perfect come in
here with your hair messed up one day
you always have to look so perfect i was
like okay
but i really i really made a bond with
him and i i think what it is
for someone like me and i'm sure for
other people when people are really good
to you and you haven't had much of that
in your life you never forget those
people i've never forgotten him i just
spoke to him on the phone
you know i'm 47 now i was 29 when i met
him i just spoke to him on the phone the
other day
i loved that man and
he was an angel
you know and there were so many
parallels with him and my dad being from
texas dallas cowboys ex-preacher you
know it was just very ironic
um
so after i got out of there
i stayed sober for a while and then i
moved back up to the bay area started
doing hair again i was a hair colorist
for 20 years
and um
i started using meth again and i was
like god damn it
here we go and i just was like i can't
do this again i won't do this again
so i decided to go to aa
and i know we're not supposed to talk
about a.a.a and press radio film
whatever blah blah but i'm going to um
i think it needs to come out of the
shadows stop being such a secret there's
nothing shameful about going to a.a
it's
takes a lot of strength to ask for help
um
so an interesting thing happened when i
got sober that time when i was in sober
living by the sea they were always
trying to bust me for like hooking up
with guys like who are you hooking up
with we don't get because i wouldn't
relapse i never relapsed because i was
really strong like once i set my mind to
something i pretty much stick with it
um
but i never you know i was still really
scared of guys but for some reason when
i went to aaa i became sexually active
like promiscuous and all of a sudden it
kind of came out of nowhere i was 33 at
the time
um
and i hooked up with a guy
who i didn't really like we didn't
belong together and i got pregnant
and so
at 34 i had an abortion it was actually
my second abortion i had a i had an
abortion at 23 when i was dating the
drug dealer and that was kind of a
no-brainer
you know i was addicted to meth my life
was a mess i wasn't gonna
bring a child into this world um
[Music]
so yeah uh
that was really painful
i
looking back now i feel like that baby
should have been here
and
you know i think the biggest mistake
that we make as humans is playing god
and i was playing god
i i stopped
a soul from you know embodying a human
existence
and i've you know had to live with that
and at the same time you know i was just
doing the best i could again i was super
overwhelmed the thought of having a
child i mean the truth is i needed a kid
like i needed a hole in my head but i
could have given it up for adoption i
could have done you know many other
things
so
that was super painful
um
and then i started just turning to like
spirituality meditation i would meditate
for hours
because i wasn't going to turn to drugs
again
and i saw things in meditation it was
really interesting the spiritual
connection that i was able to make
whoever was there with me showed me the
circle of life you know how we never die
it's like
we're born and we have this experience
and then we leave our human body and
become spirit and then it kind of goes
again so it's just
it showed me that there really is no
such thing as death
that we you know that we've been taught
there's physical death we leave our
bodies but
there's definitely more than what we
we see here
and um
i'll share something this is kind of
bizarre
it was november of 2011 and i was
working a lot doing hair and sunday
mornings i would always just lay in bed
that was just like my thing i would lay
in bed and rest and
i remember it was about 10 a.m
and i was you know opening my eyes and
closing my eyes and just kind of
drifting in and out of sleep and then
all of a sudden i heard
sort of a static electricity noise like
a buzzing like z
and i was like what the hell what is
that you know and so i kind of went to
get up and i couldn't i was completely
paralyzed
and so i just laid there and the sound
got louder
and i couldn't move my body and as i i
looked to my left side there was some
sort of
being standing there
it had shape but it wasn't solid
and it was very very tall
and it
put something into the side of my head
and um i just laid there and i was like
what the [ __ ] is going on and then as
soon as i kind of like
started to you know i kind of was able
to move it was over
and i ran into the bathroom and i looked
at my head and i was like
there was nothing wrong with my head and
i called a good friend of mine who kind
of
you know knew a lot about other beings
and aliens and stuff like that and she
was like oh yeah that stuff happens all
the time it's no big deal they were just
rewiring your brain
i was like
okay you know if i tell people this
they're gonna think i'm crazy she didn't
think i was crazy
so i kept meditating and just like
astral traveling and going deeper into
this other place and
it was the end of february of 2012
and at that point i was creating so much
stillness within myself and in my life
that i could i could hear things not
voices you know nothing like that but i
would hear like a soft voice that would
talk to me and give me guidance and
um
i wouldn't notice negative things like i
can remember being out with a bunch of
girlfriends and someone would be rude to
me and they'd be like did you hear that
you know what i'd be like what are you
talking about you know i was just sort
of like in this higher
level of consciousness it was really
beautiful and it was very much a relief
and it wasn't drug
induced so i'm sitting on my floor in my
house and i hear
this very soft voice that's like
elizabeth call your mom
and i was like i hadn't talked to my mom
in a year you know our relationship was
very difficult and
it persisted so i was like okay i'll
call my mom i called my mom and we made
plans to meet that next monday
for lunch
and i realized i i had to change our
plans so i called the house and my dad
answered the phone and mind you i hadn't
talked to him in 13 years
and he answered the phone and i just
said dad
and he instantly started to cry
because you know i'm his only daughter
so he knew it was me
and he just said you know elizabeth i've
i've prayed for the day that you would
talk to me again
and whatever i did to you i'm so sorry
and so we sat on the phone together and
cried for a little bit and i said dad
you know
i don't know why i'm reaching out to you
guys i don't know what's going on and i
can't promise you anything but i i want
to show up and be a loving presence in
your life
to the best of my ability
and he said i'd like that
and so i talked to my mom and we changed
our plans and um
the next day i went to work
and then saturday morning i'm laying in
my bed
and i get a call from my little brother
and he's crying
and i was like john you know this kid's
he's a tough kid he doesn't cry
and he said liz steve's dead
and steve was my older brother not the
oldest brother but the one that lived
here he
he made quite a life for himself he
became pretty famous
imitating politicians for a living
and i said what
and he said yeah he's dead they found
him
his housekeeper found him on the couch
dead
and in that moment i knew what that
voice was that that that guidance was
telling me you know your family's going
to need you
and
how difficult it would have been to have
not spoken to my dad for 13 years and
then seen him for the first time because
of that
and i just said thank you god thank you
for
guiding me and i was so grateful that i
listened
that i listened to that voice
so i got out of bed and i just said you
know what this is your this is your time
to get to suit up and show up and i was
sober thank god you know i wasn't a mess
i was able to to go towards my family
and actually be strong for them
and losing my brother steve
it was a tragic thing but it was also a
very beautiful thing he he lived an
amazing life and the way he died
reflected how he lived he just passed
away on his couch he laid down to take a
nap
and he was 48 years old
and he left behind money and he blessed
my entire family with money that's why i
haven't worked i haven't had to work
it changed my life
it was like
finally
i have this space that i can just
get to know myself that's what i've
that's what i've been doing for the past
i would say 10 12 years
is just exploring healing
you know getting to know other people
learning how to love
that's been a big thing is learning how
to love learning how to be in
relationship with others
so i i think my brother
he was an angel
he is an angel
he's here right now i can feel him
so
you know i walked through his passing
and then shortly after
my mom came down with alzheimer's she
couldn't handle you know what had
happened you know steve was her her
everything and so she lost her mind and
died four years later from alzheimer's
and
i remember my brother calling me saying
you know liz mom hasn't had food or
water in five days
so i think it's time you know so i drove
up to the bay area
and i wasn't prepared for what i was
going to see
you know someone who's skeletal
who's dehydrated who hasn't had food
who's you know
gasping for for air
and my dad and my brother they left the
room so that i could have some time
alone with her
and
for a moment there was a split second
where i was like oh my god am i going to
end up where she is because she's my mom
you know
and i just said no you're not because
you've chose a different path
i've i've chose to face myself
and she didn't and
this is where she ended up
and i just told her i looked at her and
you know she was in a morphine haze i
just said mom i love you and i forgive
you for everything and i just want you
to go and be in peace because it's never
going to happen here
and the next day she passed away
so
it was a lot
it was a lot
[Music]
and that was really hard for me i didn't
really know how to process my mom's
death because we weren't close we didn't
like each other
so unfortunately after her funeral i i
became a little bit self-destructive
and i went on like a three-day
a three-day binge
and um
about a month after that i became
severely depressed i think i was just
suppressing all the grief and all the
anger and and everything and
so i checked myself into the hospital
this was in 2016
and um
i was sitting there with a doctor and i
said i really don't want to go on
medication again i've been down that
road i'd been off of medication for
about eight years and she's like well
look where you're at you know you don't
you've kind of run out of options um so
i decided to go on medication and i take
10 milligrams of lexapro
and whatever that is in that stuff
it it corrected the imbalance
like within a matter of hours i felt
better i walked out of the hospital
a completely different person
and
i've been really really stable and and
happy since then
i've been able to deal with life on
life's terms
um
i'll be honest i'm not i'm not sober
anymore i do what's really interesting
like
you know i think that there was a time
there was an eight year period where i
was completely abstinent from everything
and i needed that time i needed that
time to heal myself and to heal my brain
and now i'm able to
have some wine if i want some wine
you know it doesn't it's not like i want
to go hurt myself so
the way i explain that to people is i
had no point of reference of what it
felt like to feel good
before i used drugs and alcohol so that
was my point of reference of feel good
and then when i became sober
in that eight year period i discovered
what it was like to just feel good
naturally
so now i have that point of reference
and feeling good naturally without
anything in your body is the best feel
good ever like it's the best
because there's no
coming down there's no hangover there's
no guilt there's you know there's no
self-destruction in that that's just
how god designed me you know all of us
we all just want to feel good
so
in the last five years i decided to go
back to school
i went to a place called the university
of santa monica is the school of
spiritual psychology
i did their two-year program
and when i was there
it was so painful i mean i really faced
a lot of pain
in a different way i mean years before i
was in and out of therapy for 11 years
and then i did group therapy on and off
for seven years
but this was different this kind of took
it to another level
and it it really changed me it made me a
better person it made me a stronger
person
and it taught me how to listen to others
and just hold space for other people
because really that's all we need is
just to be seen and heard
yeah
it was life-changing
it was great in your life what would you
say is the most important thing you've
learned
to accept what is and to love
acceptance is a big thing
just
accept what is accept what's happening
and don't try to control it
be open
beautiful story
thank you
thank you elizabeth you're welcome thank
you very much thanks